17 % de taux de verbalisation contre 5,9
pour cent au niveau national de file
début du confinement si vous êtes
contrôlés en seine saint denis vous avez
trois fois plus de risque d'être
verbalisé que partout ailleurs sur le
territoire français comment expliquer de
telles disparités
les habitants de la seine-saint-denis
serait-il moins disciplinés la
répression policière plus importante à
nous sommes allés poser la question aux
habitants de saint denis je m'interroge
à savoir si des fois sur le 9 3 s'il n'y
a pas un problème de faciès
moi je suis passé dix fois vingt fois
devant les services de police rien je
pense pas que c'est lié au racisme
la majorité des gens ici ils respectent
confinement il ya quelques mois après il
ya des jeunes nous des gens qui n'ont
rien à
donc il en avait rien à avant ils
n'ont rien à faire mais non c'est tout
j'explique cela par le seul fait que les
gens ils sont pas disciplinés
ici il ya des gens qui vivent 10 au 12
personnes dans un petit petite pièce ils
sont obligés de sortir de respirer un
petit peu je regrette si je peux me
permettre
les écarts policiers qui parfois vous au
delà de leurs compétences et au delà de
leurs fins d'un côté humain ce nombre
élevé de contravention n'a pas échappé à
la procureure du département et parmi
les facteurs qui pourraient justifier un
tel écart avec la moyenne nationale
la magistrate évoque une population très
jeune une densité très importante
un habitat qui rend difficile de rester
chez soi à plusieurs des jeunes
verbaliser notamment en bas des
immeubles et parfois même à plusieurs
reprises et enfin le trafic de
stupéfiants qui n'a pas cessé
des contrôles policiers et des
contraventions comme seule réponse à la
population pour madjid messaoudene
conseiller municipal à saint denis
le gouvernement a délibérément décidé de
laisser le champ libre à la police pour
gérer le confinement la seule forme
d'état convoi en seine saint denis
pendanx c'est pareil de confinement mais
en fait c'est la forme répressive de la
police qui est là effectivement non pas
pour aider à ce que le confinement se
passe le mieux possible mais pour
verbaliser et réprimer toutes les
personnes qui seraient dehors parce
qu'ils ne devraient pas l'être et je
pense que l'étape a pris en compte les
conditions spécifiques de certains
quartiers
je suis pas surpris par ce taux de
verbalisation mais je sais ça conforte
en tout cas l'idée que la police aiment
venir davantage faire du chiffre
chez nous qu'à paris je rappelle qu'à
paris récemment ça à danser sous un
balcon et des personnes n'ont pas été
verbalisé pour autant pour ce
département de la seine saint denis l'un
des territoires les plus touchés de
l'île de france
beaucoup ont aujourd'hui l'impression
que ces chiffres sont révélateurs des
inégalités dévoilée par cette crise
sanitaire